a warning this report from sky's katie
barnfield does contain flash photography
right from the start
since quitting his role as a senior
royal prince harry's life has been
focused in america but he says he and
his family can no longer even visit the
uk
because of a decision not to allow them
police protection a decision he's now
challenging in court
another headache for the queen this time
he is seeking a judicial review against
the decision by the home office this is
perhaps the beginning of a process
whereby harry wants to try and return to
the uk to visit to to pick up the
threads of his family life in the wider
in the wider family but it of course
comes up against the fact that he has
um you know in many cases broken
relations and raised suspicion and
unease and upset from what he's been
saying and doing in the us
harry and megan wanted to bring their
baby daughter lily bette over to meet
the queen in the year that she
celebrates her platinum jubilee but
without a police god he says it's too
dangerous for her and his son archie
the last time he was in the uk was last
july when he joined his brother the duke
of cambridge to unveil a statue of their
mum princess diana in the gardens of
kensington palace
the day before the unveiling prince
harry came here to kew gardens for a
charity event with seriously ill
children but says as he left his car was
chased by photographers having lost his
mum in a car crash when she was being
followed by paparazzi he says the
incident has left him afraid for his
family's safety when they're here in the
uk
harry is arguing his u.s security team
doesn't have the right jurisdiction
abroad or the access to uk intelligence
that they need
he's also offering to pay for the
policing himself
rather than asking the taxpayer
but a former royal protection officer
says allowing this would be
unprecedented
in my
71 years of being on this earth i've
never known anyone to pay personal
protection officers from scotland yard
to carry out protection it's unheard of
the only reason anyone gets protection
at that level is if they warrant it
in a statement his legal team said
prince harry inherited a security risk
at birth for life while his role within
the institution has changed his profile
as a member of the royal family has not
nor has the threat to him and his family
the government says its protective
security system is rigorous and
proportionate the judge will now decide
if the case meets the threshold for a
full hearing until then harry and megan
and the rest of the royal family will
stay oceans apart katie barnfield sky
news